[Music]
joey joins us in fort myers florida joey
welcome to the ramsey show
thank you thank you um so i have a
question so i am all cut off on my stuff
i do have a car payment for the next two
months zero percent interest no issues
it's like a thousand dollars um but i do
have 120 000 in the bank right now i
have a potential additional 120 to 130
000 in the bank if i need it um and i'm
currently in an apartment for the next
four months
and i'm trying to figure out what should
i do i i want to invest in real estate
potentially it sounds great on facebook
a lot of benefits but i still need to
become more educated around it
um but you know i was thinking of
instead of buying a single family home
buying a new price or or a quadplex
um but but really i'm kind of just in
the ether at this point with all the
options but no options at the same time
because i'm not that educated on it so
i'd love some advice how old are you
i'm 33 33 about my age all right and
what's your income
uh it's 105 000 a year fantastic
and tell me this where is all this money
coming from that you've got in the bank
have you just been saving for a few
years now yeah yeah yeah i uh i have a
pretty good job
obviously and uh just been saving um and
being a little frugal so yeah
very impressive and you said you have
potentially another 120 in the bank what
does that mean
[Music]
and had an addition made a hundred
thousand off of it um and i gave it to
my mom because she helped me buy the
house um but she is uh she's demanding
that i take it back but i i want it to
be hers because it's kind of my payback
for her so um if i need it i have it so
you gifted this thing to her and she's
like no take this back i don't want it
basically yeah interesting well that's
nice of you so you're not brand new to
this real estate game
since you flipped a house
well here's the thing you mentioned at
the beginning that you have this car
loan and you mentioned that at zero
percent so you're not worried about it
what is this car loan how much
uh it's only 800 bucks left 800 to 900
and i could pay it off tomorrow you owe
900 total on this car debt
yeah yeah and you have 120 000 in the
bank
correct is this sentimental what's going
why don't you just pay the car off today
it's just i just oh if it's zero percent
of zero percent i don't care if it's a
hundred percent this is stupid to carry
around a debt when you have 120 000 it's
a math equation
yeah yeah i i see that do you have any
other payments in your life is this your
only debt you have
that's it yep other than my rent payment
yep wow i mean you've done really well
man i don't know what's making you hang
on to to payments but i think you need
to say no to payments for the rest of
your life and become extra wealthy i
mean you're doing so great otherwise
yeah so so should i what should i get
into to potentially you know to grow
that that money
um should it be in in rental properties
um
what are your products clearly that's
something you're passionate about and so
what i want you to do is once you pay
off the car today which you're going to
do as soon as we're off the phone
get rid of that debt and then i want you
to park some of that money for a fully
funded emergency fund you already have
it in cash so figure out what one
month's expenses looks like for you and
uh are you single
i am okay i would probably lean towards
that six months since you already have
in cash so take one month of actual
expenses not income multiply that out by
six and leave that in maybe a high yield
savings account and park it there for
emergencies
okay then whatever money's left after
that are you currently investing into
retirement
i am yeah
okay
uh i'm gonna let you continue doing that
because this is all gonna be solved in a
matter of hours so i'm not gonna tell
you to pause investing because you're
about to pay this car off you already
have the money for your emergency fund
so are you investing 15 into uh
something like a 401k at work
uh i am not actually what are you
investing in
um not well i'm doing 401k but not 15
um seen the returns um and then kind of
kind of some of my side hustles i was
deciding to spend that money on some of
those side hustles which um
yeah
okay
well uh here's here's what uh what i
recommend what we teach is to do 15 and
you can do it if you've got a match at
work do it up to the match and then you
can open up a roth ira and fill that up
the max is 6000 for you and then go back
to the 401k and keep filling that out if
you don't have a roth option once you do
fifteen percent then you're on to baby
steps five and six which is saving for
kids college do you have kids
i do not no kids so you're moving on to
paying off your house early um which
you've got a property already that's
paid for
no i'm gonna i'm literally renting in an
apartment but the one your mom is in
oh yeah that i did we paid that off okay
so i think your next goal is to find a
primary residence for you to live in and
pay that off i wouldn't go getting into
real estate investing quite yet
okay
so uh you're in the fort myers area i
would start looking at what houses cost
over there if that's where you're
planting roots and say all right if i
wanted 20 or more down i mean a guy like
you it wouldn't shock me if you were
able to pay cash for a house
with with your income and your diligence
with saving but i'm not going to be mad
at you if you can put 20 down and avoid
pmi that private mortgage insurance
that's going to avoid you throwing money
away to protect the banks
and so once you do that and you pay off
your house early then we can start
talking about real estate investing
um as you live and give like no one else
in baby step seven so that's where that
would fall i'm all for real estate
investing i think it's fantastic i think
you're going to do really well with it
but there's a time and a place for it
and you're you're real close but you've
got a few things to do before that
okay
absolutely i appreciate it yeah man way
to go love hearing stories like that
joey pay that car off buddy